my name is Melanie my name is ELISA I
had an abortion when I was 24 when I was
18 I had an abortion and I basically
missed a pill I was on birth control I
got a pregnancy test and I was pregnant
basically I was college bound and not
interested in having children so I knew
it was the right decision because I
didn't want to be I didn't want to be a
single mom at 17 so I went and got a
pregnancy test at the health center I
was in college they didn't do a good job
of you telling me what my options were
as a quick turnaround for me I didn't
think twice about it I knew exactly what
I wanted after I found out I was
pregnant and made the decision to have
an abortion I immediately told a close
friend of mine who lived in the city and
then I told my sisters the last person I
told in my family was my grandmother
everyone that I told I told specifically
because I felt that I would be supported
by them and I was I didn't regret the
actual abortion I know I made the right
decision for myself at that moment in my
life
I didn't
the regret that I felt was that I wasn't
at the right point in my life to have a
child and that's what hurt the most um I
want to be a mother and I know I'm going
to be a great mother I just I'm not
there right now and I want to make sure
that when I have my first child that I'm
completely prepared and that I'm ready
to go and there's no concern over you
know financial security or or me having
a partner or people around me to support
me
women make a decision to have children
and it can be a really critical decision
for one person's life and there's a lot
of flexibility around that that decision
making that choice being able to call
yourself a parent or to carry a
pregnancy to term and that doesn't exist
for abortion it all comes from the same
place it's a reproductive decision you
know we live in a country who
who doesn't provide access to
comprehensive sex education doesn't
teach people how to protect themselves
from pregnancy and then when a person
does become pregnant because they don't
know how to protect themselves and they
think they couldn't pay for birth
control we tell them that having an
abortion is the wrong thing to do when
in fact it's entites entirely up to them
once they have a child that they can't
afford and didn't want we then reject
them for asking for social services from
the country it's a really disgusting
vortex of oppressiveness if someone had
forced me to have that child or if I
didn't have the option to have had that
child I don't know where my life would
be and yeah I'm really grateful that I
did have the option and I can't can't
imagine that there might be a time where
we don't have the option I don't regret
having my abortion
sometimes I wonder if I should because
there is stigma around that but that's
not coming from a genuine place inside
my heart I feel as if women are expected
to feel guilty about their abortions and
without the support and convictions that
I had and that I was able to nurture I
might I might have fallen to that shame
to that regret to the stigma but I
didn't and I don't